alright it looks like we are now live
hopefully the sound quality is pretty
good I'm here on my laptop using my blue
snowball mic
[Music]
Oster
[Music]
hey cuz well a beautiful day here in
Milwaukee Wisconsin it's overcast it's
nice out outside we we just went down to
the the east side the little upper east
side to meet with a friend of ours for
what's supposed to be a stoic walk and
talk but the weather didn't really admit
of it so we sat and chatted about some
things I got my grading done for the
online class that is just finishing up
so I'm ready to do this so let me look
at the questions that we have there
already three big ones so let me get get
started on those Harold
yes can I say a few words about the
philosophy of Spinoza and the main
similarities and differences between his
philosophy and the Stoics and this is
something that a lot of people have
pointed out that there are a lot of
similarities so I'll probably stress the
difference is a bit more because I think
that we don't want to confuse the two of
them that much these two different well
we could call Spinoza school right
because there are many spinozzi ins who
follow after him so where are they
similar the you know they both have a
monistic conception of of substance and
you know the Stoics think that there's
essentially one main substance and
everything is essentially modifications
of it in one way or another local modes
of it well it's been also thinks
something similar but they're you're
they're a bit different in how they
conceive of that you know Spinoza has
got those two attributes and then modes
and he's got a very mechanistic way of
treating things the Stoics are not
really
mechanistic in that respect and you know
the how else are they similar well they
both have analyses of the emotions you
can see this in Spinoza's ethics and you
know they're they're they're both
adopting an ethic ultimately that says
that we need to bring the passions under
our control rationality should be
dominating but there are some really
important differences you know I
mentioned the the ways in which
substance is conceived of are different
in them and another thing is you know
Spinoza rejects final causality entirely
and the Stoics they fit into the ancient
world you know final causality the idea
that that there's sort of a rationality
and purpose built into things
um Spinoza Stoics accepted that they
wouldn't say that you know it's as silly
as like you know in Candide you know why
is our I think it's our nose or maybe
it's our ears or the way they are so
that we can balance spectacles on them
much more easily that's kind of a silly
way of looking at it but you know
there's other things too you know we
often think of the Stoics as being
against the emotions and saying that we
should we should try to you know repress
them or get rid of them as much as
possible that's not actually the case
the Stoics think that that many of the
emotions are problematic but you know we
should be cultivating the rational
emotions and I I'd say that that you
know Spinoza there's less of that in
there you know
the Stoics could get behind the you know
neither laughing nor crying to the
extent that they want to avoid crying
but the laughing part you know the joy
part I think that's that's a bit
different so let's go back Greg Sandler
fan nice name
I'm currently reading works of love by
Kierkegaard I feel it helps me get a
more positive outlook on life and other
people is there more existential
philosophy in this vein that is in a
positive thing
yeah and that is something that's one of
my sort of beefs right when people talk
about existentialism and they only
really have in mind
you know jean-paul Sartre and maybe the
addition of a little bit of you know
water down Heidegger and a few quotes
from Nietzsche and Kierkegaard and then
maybe some stuff from can move
that's existentialism for them and what
they're doing there is they're buying
into sart's hijacking of the term
existentialism and pushing everybody out
of out of the use of it there are some
some existentialist thinkers who are
very much oriented towards thinking
about a you know a way of living and a
world that is not simply just absurd or
you know lacking meaning but where we
have to work to get at it and so
Kierkegaard is one of those people
Dostoevsky I would say is one of those
people to even meetcha to some extent
really fits into there there is a
positive aspect to his his work you know
you're supposed to be recovering joy in
things and he's really down on the
people who prevent us from getting at
that Gabrielle Marcel the first person
to actually use the term existentialism
in French somebody who gave up the term
once you know Sartre kind of dominated
it great example of a thinker along
those lines if you've ever read you know
we include him in the existentialist
Canon Rainer Maria Rilke a lot of room
for very positive stuff including even
like how we approach death in his works
Simone de Beauvoir she thinks that the
world is ambiguous
rather than being absurd or meaningless
I would say that her her view on
existentialism her version of
existentialism is much more positive
than that of of Sartre so those are some
people I would think let's take the next
one what do you think about Carl
Schmidt's distinction of enemy info
former being the Public Enemy
politically political enemy and the
latter being the personal or if you will
the moral enemy that's been a very long
time since I read Schmitt there was kind
of he had a kind of revival back in the
early 2000s late 90s
I mean his you know ideas that these are
sort of determinative categories for us
there is a distinction and we don't have
to go to Schmitt to find it we can find
it many other people
between the you know sort of public faux
or enemy however you want to define it
we can use whatever terms we like and
then more private things I don't know
that I would line it up along you know
political and moral lines he has a
particular conception where where
morality has become something much more
about the individual and their actions
and the political is about the entire
society so I don't know I again it's
been a while since I've read Schmidt so
I'd have to refresh a little bit OB can
or should philosophy be informed by
Lakhani and psychoanalysis yeah why not
I mean philosophy can be informed by
anything the only issue is whether you
do it well right and Lacan is difficult
to understand sometimes because of what
he's talking about sometimes because of
his deliberate you know obscurity which
is not particularly helpful I would say
he was he was and sometimes he's just
wrong right so but yeah why wouldn't we
want to incorporate insights from Lacan
or from Freud or that whole tradition I
think we would want to do that in in in
all sorts of aspects so not just you
know Lacanian psychoanalysis why not go
back to Freud why not incorporate some
things I don't I don't find you know
Union psychoanalysis like archetypes all
that that plausible oh one of our dogs
is drinking water over there you might
be hearing that on here she gets all
nervous when people are talking on the
the you know internet stuff and she
doesn't see another person being talked
to so yeah Lakhani and psychoanalysis
the trouble is is that you know it
really needs to be founded the way it
was for Lacan in actual practice and
there are practicing lakhani and
psychoanalysis out there and then
there's all the people doing cultural
studies where you kind of twist and turn
Lacan to anything you like I would say
that the start of that was you know his
use in film studies which I'm not real
fond of but you know
it can be quite useful here's a good one
from the Val
have you read Jack barzoon yeah I used
to be a big reader of barzoon
he's an interesting historian of ideas I
liked his his stuff
I don't read him very much anymore
because I just don't have the time for
it for that sort of thing but yeah I've
enjoyed quite a few of his works again
somebody was reading a lot of back in
graduate school all right
the O'Sullivan factor I don't if that's
like a show or something any tips you
could offer for reading philosophical
texts in foreign languages I can work
through books in French but it takes a
really long time thanks for all your
work well one thing I can definitely say
is that each author really has their own
lexicon you know and so you got to get
used to their vocabulary which may be
technical and may be a bit different
from that of other people so like you
know for I'll use some examples from
people that I read more frequently so I
read up at Tennyson Greek
you know and I read Aristotle in Greek
and those are two people that I've been
working on for a very long time and and
after a while you you just sort of know
their vocabulary and what the terms are
going to be signifying but a good
example of this is so both of them
actually use this term pro I racist
which in Aristotle we translate as
choice or moral choice or sometimes
deliberate deliberate choice I actually
like the term commitment for some
instances of it for a patinas Pro racist
means something a bit broader we
translated as moral purpose or Faculty
of choice or sometimes incorrectly as as
will because it's not exactly the same
as what we call the Faculty of will but
it's pretty pretty close so you know you
want to you want to accustom yourself
eventually to the vocabulary the
specific author who here you're working
in and that that will you know that's a
cumulative
and that gets better over time so don't
the other thing I'd say is don't let
yourself get too discouraged because
reading I mean so reading in French I
may be biased in this because my family
you know on my mom's side is French
Canadian so I learned some French pretty
early on but I mean I think French is a
lot closer to English in structure say
then then German well German to some
degree but let's say Latin or Greek
right so some languages are gonna take
more time to get yourself kind of into
that that framework so don't allow
yourself to get discouraged just you
know keep at it and and everything that
you're working through it's going to be
accumulating hopefully so long as you're
spending us you know a good amount of
time on it weekly Andrew writes what are
the biggest points of disagreement in
the modern stoic world wow that's a good
one so the biggest point of disagreement
is there's two one is between the modern
Stoics who are rather you know diverse
Bunch and the they call themselves
traditional Stoics now they're only
traditional in some things right I don't
think they accept every every every
single thing of classic stoic doctrine
but they view the modern Stoics as
really doing something that deviates
fundamentally from classic stoicism so
that and they've got their own you know
like organizations and and people that
they they look to as you know important
within the modern field and they're
really a minority the modern stoic field
is much broader and I would say that we
constantly because it's a growing
movement we constantly have a lot of
people playing catch-up and opining
about all sorts of things because they
get very enthusiastic or very very
worked up or they bring their personal
problems essentially to the stoical
community and act them out within that
so people can get very
very worked up over whether stoicism
must be atheistic or you know you know
you know pantheistic or whether a theist
could be a stoic people here's the thing
if you're a stoic you shouldn't get so
worked up over that sort of thing right
but people do get very worked up over
that they also get very worked up over
like what is the most important
principle and that's kind of a you know
a dumb question because there isn't one
most important principle there's a whole
bunch of important principles that are
all connected together in a network all
you gotta do is read you know Seneca and
he talks about that or Reid Epictetus
and they talk about that but people you
know they bring these they bring these
mindsets that they they already have to
to the thing and so they get themselves
into controversies another thing would
be like who is actually a stoic and
who's not a stuck so you see endless
posts about is X TOEIC you know we just
we just published a piece of modern
stoicism reinstall system today or
rather is Jordan Peterson a stoic the
answer is no he's not there may be some
things where he he says some things that
sound kind of stoic but that's not
enough to actually be committed to
stoicism and there's places where he's
clearly you know not an alignment with
that and people get endlessly worked up
over these sorts of things I think
because they have a deep-seated need to
like be able to identify stoicism with
particular people in the present if you
want to find the the actual modern
Stoics I don't know look at the modern
stoicism team or look at other other
people in that as well so those are some
of the biggest points of disagreement oh
one other one I'll mention that is kind
of a pet peeve for me is they'll be like
these you know if you I think if you
want to call yourself a modern stoic
sooner or later you'd better actually be
reading and studying and incorporating
ideas from classical Stoics otherwise
just call yourself something different
right but there's a lot of people who
are like I don't I don't want to do the
reading I'm not doing an academic thing
I'm just going to practice it and you
know you're not really practicing
something
all you've done is read some blog posts
or listen to a few podcasts about a few
stoic practices and that again is
discussed in the stoic classic stoic
literature you know you're a stoic if
you're actually like committed to the
systematic way of life and philosophy
and that requires at least some you know
practice in reading and thinking about
the the classic text and it's not a
purely academic exercise that's the sort
of thing that people who talk about you
know street smarts versus book smarts
people who use that sort of locution
they don't have any smarts really
because intelligence doesn't doesn't
work that way
but you get a you get a good bit of that
I'll mention somebody to who I want to
single out as somebody who who got
called on this and then said you know
maybe I'll go and check out the text and
then realize that it was a good thing
for him to do that and that is Scott
Hebert with the stoic metal podcast M
ETTL e not not metal is in like you know
M et al he started out by saying that
line of well it's really just about
practice I don't want to you know get
too technical or academic with this
stuff and I and a few other people said
well you really ought to be reading the
text you know that's that's pretty
important and he went and did it and
then he's like oh yeah I see what you
guys are saying and he's you know
producing great podcasts since then so
alright let me move on read 52 in one
video you claim to have previously been
a Nietzschean but later saw as flaws can
you explain what you think nature got
right and what you think he got wrong
I'll give you a one example of something
I think he got right actually it can
work for both right and wrong
his diagnosis of what he calls result
amount which is this dynamic in which a
person who you know in in time is unable
to retaliate or to to express their
they're sort of dynamism and activity in
positive ways represses that and
eventually it becomes a sort of
disposition 1/2
and it leads to you know this spirit of
detraction the spirit of always needing
to pull things down I think there's
thing nature is quite right about that
in how the process works and how we need
to be on the lookout for this and how it
can become part of culture I think he's
also right in thinking that a lot of
egalitarian projects and movements often
are driven by result Amma and I would
also say a lot of cultural critics even
the elitists are often driven by reason
saman it's something you can almost like
see or smell in a person you know by the
way in which they talk there's a kind of
sourness to it now where is he wrong in
that I think he's wrong in his genealogy
of how that actually developed over time
and I think that he's wrong in his
blanket assertions about it you know
across the board
you know scribing it to this to this to
this to this and and we could you know
come up with other examples as well I
think Nietzsche is often somebody useful
to bring to the table but you don't want
to just be a straight-out Nietzschean I
mean there's problem and figure problems
in figuring out what would it actually
mean to be a a Nietzsche in any way and
if you were in each yet wouldn't that be
problematic because then you'd be
following Nietzsche and you really
should be making your own way as well
but you know you can you can certainly
like do things as I did in the past like
prioritize bodily strength and
development and you know sort of
toughness and resiliency and look down
on everybody else particularly those who
you know aren't you know measuring up
quite as much physically or mentally or
emotionally and you know saying I don't
really have any responsibilities towards
them and you know if you practice that
sort of thing
especially if you keep justifying it to
yourself you you really turn into kind
of a jerk and so I thought that was
important to leave behind
all right Adam writes dr. Sandler was
dianese the cynic bullied from time to
time I remember you saying something
about that in one of your videos you
please elaborate on that I don't think I
don't know if I'd said that he was
bullied he certainly encountered people
doing things to him like some kids you
know one time broke his barrel that he
was living in so city of Athens bought
him a new one they didn't buy him a
house he wouldn't lived in a house but
they bought him a new you know barrel
and like a lot of people in ancient
times he he encountered rough treatment
he was captured and enslaved for a while
you know he I'm sure he didn't make
himself very pleasant through a lot of
people doing the kind of antics that he
did as a cynic the cynics you know they
they stressed the need to cultivate
virtue as they understood it you know
against all social conventions and this
is where the Stoics kind of differed
from them Stoics that virtue is very
important it's the you know primary good
but social conventions we don't have to
just violate them for their own sake the
cynics often seem to have done that in
Diogenes is probably the worst of them
in that way so now you know did he have
people actively seeking him out to bully
him you know I imagine there were
probably some he was kind of a celebrity
in Athens so yeah and there were many
cynics after him who are kind of you
know humbugs in that way you know
they're the sort of people who you know
say that they're speaking truth to power
or holding up the mirror to society we
have all sorts of phrases for this sort
of stuff but they're really just kind of
jerks that have nothing positive to
actually offer and and are always
engaged in social critique and
oftentimes you know sort of like
deliberately living on the margins now
there could be some some among them who
are you know genuine followers of the
philosophy but but often even in ancient
times
they were you know a lot of them I think
we're kinda in it to be to enjoy getting
to talk trash to people and so they get
made fun of quite a bit you know by
later authors Greg Sadler fan asks about
Thomas Sowell's book on Marxism
I don't really know I've never read it
so I wouldn't have any idea I mean if
you want to get a better overview on
Marxism Marx is a great place to start
that's it right you can get his works
online very easily there's lots of you
know useful commentaries out there there
was actually a really nice anvil book
marks and the Marxist by Sidney hook
probably easy to find in a library good
overviews of like Marx and his you know
ideas and angles and then the
development of it over time by somebody
who was in fact associated with Marxism
all the way up until the you know he's
writing that book I think in the 50s
alright uh let's see here pig monkey I
just wanted to ask if you read much
fiction what's the last novel you really
enjoyed yeah I have an entire
speculative fiction series that I do
monthly here in the local area in
Milwaukee and I created a free course
anybody can sign up I'm a little bit
behind in posting content to it but you
can get all the the videos and resources
there and that's all you know sci-fi
fantasy horror
you know alternate history stuff last
novel that I read for that was three
against the witch world by Andre Norton
and you know I I enjoy her work it's
it's fun stuff I don't get it I don't
get that much time to read other fiction
I'm working back through the Odyssey
again for a tutorial client that's
always fun I enjoy that sort of stuff
Greg say other finances well I heard max
Turner had a big impact on the thought
of marks and
worth a read so the answer the first
questions no he doesn't have a big
impact on the thought of marks and
angles
if anybody he's more similar to
Nietzsche I would say marks actually
criticizes him at create length for his
individualism and egoism is he worth a
read yes Turner is worth reading I
actually have another tutorial client
who has me working on sterner with him
he's interesting he was one of those you
know it's hard was it actually
pigeonhole him he's he's a he's a
galleon who's an anti-fog le and at the
same time he's so he's a dialectical
philosopher operating in the wake of
Hegel but but really diverging from him
but using some some stuff from that that
whole movement to come up with some
interesting things I mean if you want to
read sort of egoism taken to its fullest
extreme sterner is definitely a place to
go all right Eric asks how did I come
about teaching philosophy and don't have
any plans for discussing lecturing and
something on the Frankfurt School Adorno
Foucault etc how did I come about
teaching philosophy well that's kind of
a long story so I'm only gonna give you
a few the notes here I think it's kind
of wandered into it really I mean I I
declared myself a philosophy major
because I'd had one good philosophy
class when I was in high school and my
mom's boyfriend told me as soon as you
get to college declare a major I looked
down the list I thought philosophy
sounded cool so I declared for that but
I also majored in mathematics as well
and then you know I graduated and I had
very little guidance sort from my my
philosophy professors at Lakeland
College Lakeland doesn't even have a
philosophy program anymore you know they
shifted that stuff out and then I took a
year off and I was you know reading and
working on my language
working actually just down the street
from where I live now at 100 East 3rd
shift security guard and working in a
cafe up an Ogden and Astor and then I
went to Southern Illinois University and
I had very high test scores so I got a
fellowship and you know I just devoted
myself to to study I was very
competitive at the time as well and I
really liked you know studying
philosophy teaching philosophy was
something I could do so I started you
know by aid for one semester and then I
started teaching my my own classes I got
to teach three classes for SIU as a
graduate student and then I started
teaching my last semester there for
Southeastern Illinois College and then
you know I moved my family to Indiana
and just started looking for jobs in the
area cuz I wanted to live with my family
like larger family on our family land
and then I started I got I picked up the
Ball State job teaching in Indiana State
Prison and I just sort of you know fell
into it and continued with it
I guess the more interesting question
would be like why did I leave academic
philosophy and I haven't completely I
mean I'm gonna be teaching two classes
next semester for Marquette just down
the road over there and and one class
for Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design over there I'm fortunate I can
walk to both places I'm sort of like a
you know a hired gun and I get brought
in to teach classes here and there by
people but yeah so there is kind of a
long story
all right so the other part do you have
any plans for discussing lecturing
something on the Frankfurt School Adorno
food called sure it's always a matter of
finding the time and that is always a
matter of finances and so this is a good
plug for talking about patreon if you
like the sort of stuff that I do and you
want to see me have you know more
capacity to do more stuff
then you want to become a patreon
supporter because you know if you look
at the site you see all these goals that
I've set like the next goal is to start
converting some of my videos into
podcast episodes and then you know
eventually just restart the
existentialism series start building out
the critical thinking series
yeah and I'll probably do some stuff on
Foucault who I think it's pretty
interesting it's a matter of finding the
time which is a matter of having the
income to not spend so much time on on
all these other endeavors to try to
bring in bring in money Frankfurt School
sure I mean I actually might one of my
the very first articles that I wrote was
on Adorno so he's somebody who had been
a fan afore a long time
Adorno was very difficult to talk about
though because his work I mean Hegel is
incredibly complex Adorno is even more
complex than Hegel but yeah I'll
definitely be doing some stuff on other
continental thinkers Zanna writes how
much are you interested in poetry who is
your inspiration in that regard can we
draw a very concrete distinction between
philosophy and poetry I'm not a great
reader of poetry as poetry again I think
that's more a matter of I I don't have
the time to really linger over poetry
the way I would like to I've enjoyed it
a lot more in the past when I had a lot
more leisure and there are some people
who I do read pretty regularly
you know rainer maria rilke for example
you know i read his stuff pretty pretty
often there's some philosophers who
wrote their stuff in poetry you know be
theists the consolation of philosophy
every chapter there is like it starts
with a poem and then there's the prose
you know and and it's okay I just I you
know poetry is something that requires
time to devote to you know if we're
talking about classic poetry and then of
course we've got the contemporary poetry
stuff which
I just don't find very interesting much
of the time and unfortunately but that
this is me you know can we draw a very
concrete distinction between philosophy
and poetry yes in general I mean poetry
is really focused on doing something
with language in terms of the language
expressing images can I mean you can do
philosophy in poetry Pope is a great
example of an author who does that you
know he's got his whole critique of
Locke in a long poem
you know Parmenides you know wrote a
poem at the start Plato is is a big
basher of the poets but he's also
somebody who can incorporate poetry into
his works let me go back up I missed
read what do you think is the most
valuable contribution of Heidegger
what's the best way to approach reading
primary texts with his second one I
don't really know I mean you start
reading them you know and then expect
not to understand much of what you're
reading the 1st 2nd 3rd 4th time around
and you know see what what resources you
can find to help you understand what the
hell he's talking about but don't have
too high expectations of that or or the
understanding of Heidegger and it's one
of those sort of things where it's a
cumulative process right you you have to
stick with it for a while what are some
I mean myself I think that I there's a
lot of really key ideas in Heidegger but
I think the thing that I'm most
interested in believe it or not is his
treatment of the the emotions or what we
can call mood effectivity and how it is
involved in our perception of the world
and our ourselves in the world
and everybody likes to talk about
anxiety but but Heidegger you know he he
actually discusses a lot of different
moods so that's what I find most
interesting in in his work dis identity
here
interesting question do you think
crossover thinkers such as economists
psychologists etc make good philosophers
and deserve to be called one or we say
that they're not rigorous disciplined
enough well there isn't any definition
of who can be a philosopher or not I
mean different movements do it that way
so like you know continental thinkers
say they fight amongst each other a lot
but they also say like you know analytic
philosophy just you know doesn't pay
enough to attention to the text totally
right about that by the way analytic
philosophers are usually terrible
readers of historical texts but that's
not their bag right there they're doing
something different and the analytic
philosophers you know they they started
at the very beginning telling other
people that what they're doing is not
philosophy so there's a long history
well German idealism great example -
there's you know long history of
philosophers telling everybody else that
they're not really philosophers so that
that's part of the background thing I
think crossing over is perfectly fine
you know it's a question of whether
you've got the philosophical chops to do
it so if you're a psychologist and you
don't actually like know the history of
psychology which comes out of philosophy
very well and you're doing a lot of
reinventing of wheels without realizing
it then you're probably not doing very
good philosophy
I really think you can't do very good
philosophy in most areas without without
knowing some of the history of ideas of
the field and that's not just the
history of philosophers that's the
history of broader history of ideas
right it's also important to keep in
mind that many of the the important
philosophers in that history were not
one-trick ponies they were they were
doing a lot of different things so you
know line it's it's called the universal
genius of Europe in part because he
didn't just do metaphysics or ethics or
logic he also did math you know very
important stuff in mathematics I was one
of the inventors of the integral
calculus he engaged in diplomacy he was
a historian he helped to invent new
pumps and mechanics so you know it can
be quite quite good and and a lot of
philosophy actually gets
outside of philosophy departments
because of the way we've you know sort
of you know specialized in academic
philosophy but you know I think a lot of
people look at philosophy is something
they can do on the side and they can you
know they can be a physicist and on also
do philosophy yeah you can do bad
philosophy you got to actually know
enough about the field in order to
figure out where you fit in so yeah the
other thing is to should philosophers
cross over into other areas well if they
do they better know what the hell
they're talking about you know like I I
you know do a lot of consulting work and
boy if you don't if you don't know the
you know the area that you're consulting
in then you have zero credibility you
know you've got to be able to connect
that sort of stuff Ricky do you feel
that the apology has a religious
connotation I imagine you mean the
apology of Plato about Socrates giving
his defence socrates talks about the
death and the afterlife so sure it's got
got religious themes to it he also says
that he was appointed to his task by God
there's a whole discussion in there
about you know the Oracle so yeah Leo
asked can philosophy help us with
psychological issues if so why can you
help recommend some books about this
well the second one is so why you know
psychology came out of philosophy right
so so there's gonna be still some
connections between them and and yeah
ancient philosophy and medieval
philosophy and some modern philosophy
has some incredible insights on some
issues that are very helpful with with
we know particular life or psychological
issues the psychologists who by the way
are not in agreement about about a lot
of different things many schools of
psychology out there and they often war
with each other they have a more
you know they sort of take over that
Providence of dealing with the emotions
but there's psychology of emotion going
all the way back to Plato right so of
course those things can be useful I mean
I apply insights from from Plato and
Aristotle and Plutarch and the Stoics
and John Cassian you name it in dealing
with with clients helping them with some
of their issues now if you've got like
severe depression that maybe you need to
find a psychiatrist who can prescribe
you some antidepressants but you know
those are just a crutch for you know you
know fixing the brain chemistry for a
while and then you got to figure out
what you're gonna do and you could do
you know cognitive behavior therapy or
you could also like you know work
through stoic exercises or you could do
both at the same time you know there's
nothing to say that that you have to
substitute one for the other
as far as recommending books about this
I mean there's a ton of books out there
about philosophy as a way of life
applying philosophy and so there's I
don't have any particular
recommendations I would just do a google
search and you're gonna find lots of
things Jessica what are your opinions
about dragons I don't really have
opinions about dragons I guess they're
cool you know I wouldn't want to meet
one mark what is similar or different
between the Platonic and heidegger's
concept of being well I mean Heidegger
thinks that that Plato is one of the
first people in taking one particular
region as he calls it of beings and
turning that into a paradigm for being
or the being of beings itself Plato is
is part of an entire history of
metaphysics doing that sort of thing
for Plato it's it's you know according
to Heidegger oriented around being in
terms of the a toaster idea and that's
what has you know genuine being
everything else is placed in in terms of
that Heidegger wants to recover what he
calls a more original conception of
being which is
a bit more heterogeneous so I think it's
about as much as I can say about that
here William Robinson where do you think
is the most accessible work to begin
reading Conte my grandmother bought me a
copy of his introduction of logic as a
graduation gift but I'm sure I'm not
sure it's a good place to start
there is no good place to start reading
comm you just got to start reading cons
and just like with Heidegger or also
with Aristotle it's gonna take a lot of
reading before you actually figure out
what the hell he's talking about
Kant thought that you know when it came
to like the first critique that the
prolegomena to any future metaphysics
could be a good place to start
but if you've ever read that it's pretty
tough stuff I'm actually gonna do some
videos about that hopefully sometime
later this year of course there is moral
philosophy the groundwork for the the
metaphysics of morals again rather tough
stuff but the good news with that is
I've got a whole video series on that
that you could you can watch that might
help you out with that but there is no
easy place to start with can't quite
quite frankly you just got to jump in
Darkstar thanks for doing another AMA I
like a lot of the enchiridion of
Epictetus but the part where he talks
about grieving over family members is
hard for me to accept what is your view
well I wrote a piece on this that you
can find in stoicism today both in the
blog and in stoicism today volume 2
tracking about epictetus and familial
affection I think that you have to we're
talking about this actually at the the
stoic meet up today with a lot of the
things in the enchiridion you've got to
take them and contextualize them within
the larger framework of at the rest of
epictetus is writings so you you want to
think about what else he has to say
about these topics rather than just
focusing in on that one thing why why
would we want to for example kiss our
wife or child and remind ourselves that
they are mortal so that when they die
were not so upset precisely for two
reasons one is because
we often get into the wrong mindset that
the index for whether you really love
somebody is whether you get upset when
they're gone and there isn't a necessary
connection between that the other thing
is the Stoics view grief is something
bad and why wouldn't we want to try to
do what we can to do to avoid it doesn't
mean that we don't love the person or
appreciate them or care for them but it
does mean that we don't have to have
that sort of suffering that's almost
self inflicted upon us all right
Nath Iook on what are the main
differences between Heidegger and
Nietzsche well
Heidegger thinks that Nietzsche is the
last of the meta physicians he's sort of
the anti metaphysical meta physician
there's actually you know one one good
way to make sense of Nietzsche is
through reading secondary text and
Heidegger has a four-volume
set of lectures on on Nietzsche which
are pretty pretty readable pretty
accessible compared to like being in
tonight some of heidegger's other stuff
and that's probably a good place to go
to get a really good conception of how
how what he's taking from him and what's
what's different d-ashworths what's your
opinion on Collingwood's
historiographical methodology I I don't
know and I don't know enough about
Collingwood they actually say much about
that it's been a long time since I've
read them so sorry about that school Alf
live thoughts on the work of Alain de
Botton is popular philosophy been
popular philosophy is not bad but a lot
of popular philosophy is bad and I would
say that well how do you differentiate
so in order to be good it's got to
really be based in a you know full
conception of whatever it is that you're
talking about right don't don't try to
like [ __ ] people about what Plato
said and it should remain faithful to
the thinker we don't want to just deform
them you know and then the other thing
is you know there's there's too much
glitz and you know Anna you know
animated videos and stuff like that out
there that give people the impression
that they understand a philosophical
idea ten stalks are very similar to this
- I'm not a fan of TED Talks
because there's like a whole you know
you might say consumer culture out there
when it comes to ideas of giving you
something that's essentially edutainment
and it makes you feel like you've
learned something but you don't really
have much to go with and that's why I do
the kind of videos that I do just sort
of careful going through the text you
know putting stuff on the track board
giving examples treating one idea at a
time giving it the amount of time that
it needs not worrying about you know put
you know very high production stuff with
lots of cool music and cutesy wutesy
kind of stuff now I mean you can ask
yourself school of life stuff where does
it fit in with that some of the videos
can be okay you know starting points
some of them are quite frankly just you
know fluff but you know that's that's a
lot of stuff right a lot of blog a lot
of people doing blogging about
philosophy it's fluff you know a lot of
podcasts its fluff and you get what you
you invest in it right so if all you do
is read that sort of stuff well you know
you're you're depriving yourself of
really getting to be in contact with
great ideas I learned about Tom I don't
really know enough about the guy to say
much a lot of people don't like him I
don't care about him he's not here's the
thing he's not really on my radar
because I don't have the time to invest
he was it's all I will say this though
so everybody these days ask me what do
you think about Jordan Peterson all
right and it's funny because we go
through these fads right when it comes
to popular philosophy stuff so this year
it's all what about Jordan Peterson and
you know like a couple years ago it was
what about sam harris what do you think
about him
and before that it was what about Al and
about time right um it just goes like in
this faddish thing the there's not a lot
of shelf life to to these these popular
philosophy things Francis writes why did
you say in the past that Nietzsche would
think of most right-wing libertarians as
conformist Duds could you elaborate well
it's very simple because he would think
of them that way because they are pretty
conformist they're they're ant this is
this is something that's been going on
since the time of the hippies
you know waves of people being
nonconformist but all being
nonconformist in the same way parroting
the same lines reading the same
literature being edgy or you know
anti-establishment or whatever you want
in the same way Nietzsche would say that
they wind up being joiners they they're
you know engaged in marginal
differentiation from each other but
they're really in opposition to the same
stuff out here and that really the proof
of it is when you get into conversations
with them do they have thoughtful
conversations or do they have trigger
points where you know you say listen I
think this is this is the case and
they're like oh well clearly I know
you're a bad guy then you know well okay
then conversations done because takes
two thinkers to have a conversation you
know and if you take yourself out of the
loop of thought and you're doing
knee-jerk reactions oriented around you
know particular essentially idealogy
points then it becomes very boring but I
think a lot of people like that it it's
it's the same sort of consumerist meant
you know mentality when it comes to
ideas as people on the left you know or
people in in in in other respects let
men shinned people who like you know
swallow up TED talks and just parrot
that there was a guy in the cafe when I
was doing my grading and I could hear
him talking you know trying to impress
some chick who was another student and
he it was just like cliche after cliche
after cliche and I was like and the news
are all the
jiae's that like original thinkers like
to use but they're all like you know ten
years old you know in terms of the TED
talks he's been watching and I was like
god I hope that this this this this
woman listening to him is not impressed
by this drivel so I mean that's you know
that's it does that mean that everybody
who's on the right who's a libertarian
as a conformist dud no but insofar as is
you you know you're interesting it'll be
because you've got something different
to say than the rest of the libertarians
and it'll also show in how you handle
conflict and how you respond to people
and whether you can have genuine
conversations or not condo tear Oh have
you read any of the traditionalist such
as of Allah or you known what is your
opinion of them I've answered this many
times I've not read of all I've not read
your own I've actually read the real
traditionalist the people who coined
that phrase back in the nineteenth
century people like you know de-bone old
and and Joseph that mice and laminae and
you know and I've also done a lot of
work on you know Axio France says and
shall Mourad people like like that so
it's kind of funny that this term
traditionalist winds up getting used so
many different ways by so many different
people I mean I'd like to get around to
reading them I don't know that it's
gonna be worth the time but you never
know until you actually read them in
part because I do a lot of work on you
know those sorts of movements so you you
know I don't know I don't have any
opinion at this time
- do you know good writing on what
Aquinas takes as final causes I do not
because I don't spend much time on
secondary literature if you want to
understand Aquinas there's nothing like
actually reading Aquinas to do that you
know start with the Summa theologia and
start working your way through that you
know it's
accessible Thomas wrote it for beginners
as he as he tells us in the preface to
it the observer what do you think of
judo Krishnamurti I've only read a bit
of Krishnamurti so not enough to really
have much of an opinion what I've read
is interesting but but again it's it's
it's not enough to really go by Matthew
Maule can I speak to Jordan Peterson
that would depend on Jordan Peterson
wanting to speak to me right people are
always like why don't ya why don't you
have an interview with Jordan Peterson I
don't know set it up you know make it
happen and then we'll do it what do I
find particularly troublesome with him
is again something I've discussed at
great length already so I'll give you
the very thumbnail thing I think that
his is uh he uses language in a sloppy
way you know talking about
post-modernism is a great example right
post-modernism is something quite
complex you can't say Marxist or post
modernists because that they don't go
together right there are actual Marxists
are critical of post-modernism so it's
just kind of sloppy stuff that it that I
don't like and many other people do this
as well and I also think that he's
become kind of a victim of his own
success as he became a celebrity and he
started being brought on to all these
you know right-wing shows and then you
know the left wingers try to do is
playing gotcha with him I think that you
know he had some some stuff that that
had you know arguably some intellectual
substance to it although I don't think
I'm in agreement with a good bit of what
he was you know trying to say in those
early videos and in his maps of meaning
I'd only read bits of maps and meaning
did not find it impressive at all I'm
not read enough to say when people were
first recommending him say yeah I got
better stuff to spend my time on and
then you know now he's sort of
catapulted to fame and now he's got to
be a certain kind of guy right he's
invested in having a stick and you know
telling people certain things
and I think it's it's really restricted
him if he wanted to do deeper readings
taking philosophy more seriously on its
own rights I don't think he would be
able to given his audience well then
again you know they a lot of his fans
don't I I think don't really understand
everything he's saying and anything he
says they'd sort of absorb and I don't
like that either
you know I'm not a fan of big mass
follower movements that talk about
critical thinking and talk about you
know individuality but seem to promote
more essentially like I said consumerist
attitudes towards towards things you
know all right here's a good one for mr.
guy how does philosophy get disseminated
from esoteric academic circles to flaunt
to society at large philosophy seems to
have become something strictly done in
university but not accessible to
everyone
well what are we doing right here you
know I mean that strikes me as kind of
an answer there's we live in an amazing
time because of the internet when you
can literally you can access thousands
of thousands of videos on philosophy
there's there's great podcasts out there
there's people doing events I mean I I
do two or three events every single
month here in the local area that are
bringing philosophy too you know
ordinary people in one way or another
and there's many others doing that as
well there are organizations like Sophia
the Society philosophers in America we
established a chapter here in Milwaukee
right promoting public discourse about
philosophy you know there's there's all
you all this stuff available you want to
you want to get philosophy books
most of many of them are online you can
go to the library and check them out you
might be able to find a book club to
participate in now our academics
actually leading the charge with that
for the most part no there are some who
like me were full-time academics and
then you know made made a transition
there are some people who are still
full-time academics and are doing a lot
Massimo Pigliucci would be a great
example he's he's still you know
full-time professor but there's a lot of
other people outside of the academy
doing philosophy and you know this is
the way it was done for a long time I
mean Rene Descartes when he writes the
discourse on method and chooses to have
it in French rather than in Latin like
his meditations so that you know as he
says women and workers can read it right
because you know they might not have
access to Latin he's doing philosophy in
a very public way and so you know we
have a lot of models for people doing
philosophy outside of the Academy and we
have a lot of models for academies that
do a better job of outreach of bringing
in ordinary people and then we have lots
of examples of academics and academies
that that do it wrong you know so
including some that call themselves you
know public philosophers so so it's not
as pessimistic as it sounds right it's
not and and academic circles by the way
or not esoteric
you can go in and take a philosophy
class and you can probably understand
much of what they're talking about you
know go to philosophy conferences see
what what they're like you know they're
not gonna kick you out just because you
don't have an academic position they'll
actually be happy to see people
interested in this stuff right
Sani this age what's the next step after
studying existentialism study it more I
mean you can study existentialist
literature the rest of your life there's
so much there you know I mean you could
be just you know studying any one of the
great existentialist figures and keep
approaching them over and over and over
again the rest of
life because there's so much writing out
there you know what you want to study
after after spending some time
researching in a particular field that's
that's up to you there isn't it there
isn't a a you know progressive thing in
philosophy where you got to do this
first you got to do this first you got
to do this first you know that that's up
to you
Natacha which philosopher texts do you
think could help a person who feels
unfulfilled in life
it depends kind of on why they feel
unfulfilled but you you know it
certainly doesn't hurt to look at
classic virtue ethics you know from
Plato to Bowie theists I'd say and
beyond helping us to sort of think about
the goods in life and where which ones
we enjoy and where we fit in with them
and how we orient them to each other and
whether our our ways in which we you
know we structure our life might be a
bit misguided and then we can
restructure our life and then maybe feel
a bit better about it - how does how
does one go about defending naturalism I
don't know because I don't have any
interest in defending naturalism I'm
sure there's plenty of people out there
if they're qualified that's like about
that and then I am I don't have any any
interest in in defending naturalism or
something beyond naturalism as a matter
of fact a lot of philosophical debates
or defenses wind up being a lot of time
spent on getting very little
accomplished you know I'm more
interested in understanding what people
are saying given you know the years that
I have left and then trying to think
about whether their their viewpoints are
plausible or not the proof architects
thoughts on Thomas Kuhn and his coinage
of term paradigm shift in structure of
scientific revolutions
yeah that's somebody who we had to study
when I was in graduate school and that
was a popular term I don't see anything
wrong with it it got kind of trivialized
as it made its
into the larger culture I think so that
now like you know you you uh you hear
potato chips right and and putting them
in a tube rather than in a bag there's a
paradigm shift no that's not quite a
paradigm shift right but you know it's
very useful I think and explained in the
way that he does it in explaining how we
go from one sort of overarching view on
what constitutes science into another
one you know so it can be quite quite
helpful proof architect also thoughts on
Leibniz theodicy it's a very interesting
book I think some of the arguments are
not particularly good but that's very
entertaining and pointed it draw a lot
of fire from people oh ok the o'sullivan
factor best song to work out - best type
of song to work out - well you know for
me metal I don't know what you're into
but thank god there's metal because I
can't stand listening to the drivel that
they play the pop stuff at these gyms
where I work out especially at the one
right downtown where it's all these
college kids playing contemporary pop
music I listen to classic metal I would
say if I had to just pick one one song
that I really like the best it's black
sabbath's zero the hero who I kind of
you know halfway identify with in a way
as a matter of fact if I ever like
really really make it big like big
enough where I could purchase song
rights to walk out on stage I would love
to have the the riff not from the very
beginning but from the middle point as
my walk out music because it's so great
uh Greg say other fan who was right
about the state of nature so we're
talking about like you know Hobbes or
Locke or Rousseau or people like that I
don't know that any of them are actually
right about the state of nature it seems
like it's it's a lot you know more
complicated than any of the things that
people might might say you know so III
mean it's a cool idea the state of
nature but I don't know how how useful
can we say that one of them is not right
one I don't I don't know oh there's a
lot of questions here I'm not gonna be
able to answer everything that's in here
they've piled up as usual I'd scrolled
and it ran out a little bit let me see
what we've got next and we're gonna go
over time as usual we should be ending
right now but we'll go maybe another
half an hour so as usual though so so
House ladies Ramirez Gregory Sadler is
the definition of self centered in
arrogance I don't know what you're doing
here if you think that's the case but
everybody's entitled to an opinion right
curveball
what's your opinion on Donald Trump and
Mike Pence well I'm not a fan of Trump I
you know I find a lot of the stuff that
he does just an embarrassment I think
it's also dangerous that I see a lot of
these people who are like you know my
president right or wrong you know I'm
gonna I'm not gonna vote for anybody
unless they're totally unlock stuff with
Trump I think that's doing a terrible
number on the already quite badly off
Republican Party here in the United
States and you know I am I just I I
don't I don't align with either party
but I think that Trump is
is really bad news pence is an
interesting guy he's sort of a typical
you know values republican I don't you
know I don't have the sort of automatic
antipathy towards him
that some people on the Left do or
they're like Oh Trump gets out of the
way Pence is gonna be even worse I mean
I don't I don't find either of them
people that I would want to work with
but I didn't vote for either the major
parties in this election I couldn't find
myself in good conscience doing so it's
interesting too because you know there's
a long tradition I remember talking with
with Paul Griffiths about this and and
you know we're talking about Allister
McIntyre's discussion back in the early
2000s about why you know it wasn't good
to vote for Republicans or Democrats and
then what's your option do you vote for
a third party do you a principled non
vote you know all of that sort of stuff
and we had some great conversations
about that
Hassam asks have you read George Holland
Sabine's work in history political
theory no I haven't unfortunately mark
no I'm Tom ski in his book and talk your
5:01 quotes lectures on philosophy of
history where Hegel writes things okay I
don't know what that means
[Music]
wallet she and dr. Sadler is there
anything of worth and Dawkins meme
theory or is it all garbage well that's
an interesting question I mean the
notion of meme itself is kind of you
know it I think then the idea that they
reproduce themselves over time and they
they compete against each other yeah
there's something to that I don't know
it's been a long time since I've looked
at that cuz that was kind of popular
years and years ago all right getting
some racist stuff in here that's held
for review I don't know why people chime
in you know
miss with racist stuff there's plenty of
other like you know forums to do that
sort of nonsense right chase asked about
Caine's theory of radical uncertainty I
I you know I don't have any views on
that because it's not anything I've
looked at for I
I read canes years and years and years
and years ago and I don't really
remember much of what I read quite
honestly there was a phase where I was
like I got to read all the Economist's
proof architect best movies and comics
that can engage you in deep philosophy
that's an interesting question I mean
there's there's all sorts of great
things like you know memento and Dark
City that I've used in classes right
Exorcism of Emily Rose I used to use in
philosophy of religion class cuz it's
got a nice tripartite distinction
between different points of view I am
really a fan of this show West world
which i think is doing an incredible job
in raising all and embodying that's the
cool thing about narratives they embody
philosophical positions in in amazing
ways and and usually the studios find
some way to really you know homogenized
it or screw it up that hasn't happened
so far in in West world so pretty good
stuff and you know there's other things
out there sort of these anthology series
black mirrors doing a pretty good job
there's that you know that worlds if I
don't know if I'm getting it right the
world's a philip k dick i mean dick is a
great you know philosophical and a
writer so yeah so red car rude you do
you think arjuna from the gita satisfies
Kierkegaard's criteria as a knight of
faith three packages of knight of dharma
that's an interesting question i have
never thought about that no no
because there is what what is being
articulated to Arjuna is in essence sort
of an ethical order and not the leap
into their religious but that's a really
interesting question alright Thomas More
what do I think about Buddhist
approaches to anger compared to stoicism
do I want to riff on the theme I'll just
say this I haven't done enough work on
Buddhism and anger there's a lot of
interest in texts out there and say much
I think that there's a lot of
similarities in in how how they reframe
things to think about it but Buddhism
and I was a story about this today
Buddhism and stoicism are very very
different on the conception of the self
and I think that that influences things
in that case all right I'm gonna try to
go through things fairly quickly and
then the last 20 minutes
Kenneth how do you find motivation
within philosophy one gets burned out
asking as an undergrad I got burnt out
as an undergrad I had what they call
senioritis I just wanted to get the hell
out of there and I was spending a lot of
time working out and drinking and and
you know having one affair after another
and enjoying life and sometimes getting
in fights not my coursework although I
was finishing up my senior thesis at the
time on truth self-referential statement
groups so I don't know when you get
burnt out on one area do reading in
another area so like you know if you're
getting burnt out reading sort of
standard philosophical fare we'd read
fiction than as philosophical themes you
know like you know I mentioned philip k
dick he's a good writer if you're into
that sort of thing or don't stay up ski
or you know I don't you picked something
more contemporary I'm not a big reader
of contemporary literature but there's
lots of cool stuff out there that helps
me you know and don't try to push
yourself to be motivated what I'm
motivated
so alright Muhammad does Nietzsche want
religion to exist within what he could
the heard and what kind of religion
Christianity or Islam or whatever
Nietzsche Nietzsche in many respects
doesn't care what the the herd is going
to do the herd is pretty much
irredeemable and he's interested in
pulling out some individuals from that
herd who have the potential to be more
so I don't think he would you know like
we think we can think about like
globally right Christianity and Islam
are are two of the the world's largest
religions and there are areas like in
Africa where they're kind of competing
with each other quite a bit
you know or we can talk about you know
Hinduism and Islam and other religions
in India would need to actually care
about that
not much you'd be like well one is just
as bad as the other more or less so a an
ordered whole I've been on a practical
binge and watching your logical fallacy
videos thanks for doing those yeah I'll
put in another plug when it when I when
I reach a sufficient level of support on
patreon and I've committed to producing
more of those it's just a matter of
finding the time to do that James do you
think belief is volitional I think some
beliefs are volitional what do we mean
by that we mean that there's some sort
of you know reason why we believe in
part because we've chosen to believe in
something are all our beliefs volitional
no some people might actually have no
volitional beliefs some people might
have more there could be good or bad
reasons to believe in that way Brian
asks do you have an interest in star
wars what are your thoughts on the solo
film coming out this month well I I'm
not a fan of Star Wars I was as a kid
but that's just because I didn't realize
how you know how
we were for good space movies and
storytelling I was very you know
interested win like the new series came
out of episode one two and three and I
went to the theater and watched them and
with each of them I was like holy crap
is this garbage you know and then I was
like man these weren't as good as the
first ones and then I watched the first
ones with my kids and I was like kind of
misjudged those they're not really that
great as as stories and Luke strikes me
as just a whiny you know character you
know and and my kids were they were like
why does everyone talk so so much about
this I haven't seen the ones after that
because frankly you know I can't imagine
Disney doing anything good with them now
I do like Glover so I don't know I might
watch that that one's definitely not
something I would spend money going out
to the theater for but I'd watch it on
Netflix or something but I haven't
watched any of the the the recently done
ones so I really you know can't can't
say I just say I'm disappointed with
what happened with it but I don't think
there was that much to work with to
begin with compared to some of the other
great space series that were available
you know no you know it probably did
some good and breaking ground but that's
about it
yeah hubris likes I like my new you like
my new beard yeah well it's not that new
had this for a while looks like a
combination of Alexander Duggan's and
fjord Dostoyevsky's beards mainly I
suppose because it's white rekt Dark
Star which stoic philosopher is
particularly good for anger Seneca has a
whole book called on anger so that's
that's pretty good place to start
Aurelius has a lot of cool reflections
you got to kind of
you know piece them together because he
never does anything systematically and
epictetus has a couple chapters where he
talks about anger in particular so that
that can be good and then um I mean you
know you can you can look at Cicero's
Tusculum disputations there's some good
discussions about the emotions in there
and now course sister was not a stoic
but he is more stoic than a lot of
people and he likes the Stoics on the
emotions so go check him out
Samson what do you think about
Aristotle's explanation of moral virtues
specifically means or intermediates I
think properly understood he's
completely right he's so good about that
that the playtest stole that from him
and then attributed it to Socrates
that's what Plutarch does in in some of
his works but you know it's not just
like a right in the middle State right
and Aristotle himself tells you there's
some actions there's no middle state for
there's no right amount of adultery to
commit so all right let's skip through
all the avala and going on stuff that
people are engaged in here and the stuff
about what what things are made of
hubris you would like to know my take on
regards to mysticism mythology and so on
mysticism is a term that means many
things if we're talking about classical
mysticism I think it's quite cool and
interesting but there we're talking
about like gluttonous and neoplatonism
right I'm not talking about crystals and
you know walking the labyrinth through
that sort of sort of stuff right or or
esoteric readings of this or that right
we're talking about actually you know
practices that are supposed to lead to
something beyond language and I think
that that's interesting although I don't
I don't claim any any competence
whatsoever in that mythology I'm very
interested in mythology have been since
I was a kid I know I've already I've
kicked around the idea of doing like a
series on on you know mythology but just
don't have the time to do it at this
point I might put that as another idea
for patreon levels you know once I reach
enough enough support my son and
daughter are also very interested in
mythology and maybe I'll collaborate
with them eventually on that sort of
thing now you know I do think that you
know we we want to try to figure out
well what is a myth really saying and we
also want to like not disney fire
sanitized myths you know I think that
that's kind of kind of important to
Jakob you might have answered this
before but have you ever been engaged in
the thought of Deleuze yeah I started
reading to lose with you know his
collaboration with with guitar II back
as an undergraduate I I never really
really got into Deleuze and most of the
people who I met who were super into
Deleuze were kind of jerks and didn't
want to read anybody else I really like
des loses books on you know historical
figures and I like his critical essays
when it gets to like straight to lose
I'm not quite so interested in that but
you know he's somebody who who I've read
quite a bit of Arvid mom is the sadler
active on lit I am NOT and but I do view
every once in a while take a look at
what people are saying on that ever
since the the Hegel guy who I know I'm
blanking on it's aw what is his last
name clued me into the fact that people
were were interested in my work there
but if you ever see somebody chiming in
and saying hey this is dr. Sandler
they're full of crap because I don't
yeah I don't use that that platform
right I already I'm already pretty busy
with Twitter Facebook Google+ LinkedIn
and then keeping in touch with my
patreon supporters I don't even use
reddit I have sporadically in the past
but it's just not worth the time oh and
I do use Korra but yeah I don't I don't
really do that
but it's kind of cool people make funny
memes
I don't really you know mind that every
once in a while somebody will bash me on
lip and then people will try and min and
say Hayes making good videos so that's
cool you know it's just I'm probably too
too old of a guy to really get into that
that sort of thing but yeah you know
it's nice that they they've got that
going on and I'm glad it's a way people
run into my work they seem mostly
interested in the half-hour Hegel videos
which is kind of funny but that's that's
fine you know let's see what else we got
here
hubris do you think Heidegger's
understanding of being reduces the
eidetic science of philosophy to a
humanist anthropology Heidegger is not a
humanist so I don't that be kind of a
non-starter there I think he's you know
read the letter on humanism to start
with because we're Sartre was claiming
existentialism as a humanism our Jonas
individualism versus communitarianism
who wins nobody wins that one's never
finished right Mohammed how to confront
a father when we've not been able to
keep promises or to keep trust
maintained well the I'm not sure what's
being asked about like how to deal with
a father when you haven't kept promises
or when they haven't kept promises I
mean epictetus would say you know you
can focus on your role and and realize
the fact that nothing in the universe
guaranteed you're gonna get a good
father you just got a father and it's up
to you what you want to do with that but
that means that there's there's probably
some things where you don't you you know
you if somebody crosses certain lines
you say I just can't deal with you
anymore now they can be very different
difficult if you're still stuck in
somebody's house so gondola who do you
find to be the most interesting
pre-socratic philosopher that's a good
question
who do I find the most interesting and
we don't have that much from these guys
I guess I would say permanent no no I
would say Zeno
you know you know with his paradoxes
right working off of Parmenides I
actually found that fascinating enough
to write papers on that when I was an
undergraduate so yeah that's probably
the guy doc what's your full-blown
opinion on Chopin hour I think shrimpin
hours somebody really cool to study I
don't buy his metaphysics but I think I
enjoy reading his writing and I had the
opportunity to actually study with
Schirrmacher the one time president of
the International shwoop and our society
and hear his theory of the the sort of
standard fare Schopenhauer the
pessimistic Schopenhauer and then the
the more optimistic Schopenhauer that he
was he was putting out so that one that
was kind of cool
but I have to admit I haven't been
reading Schopenhauer much since that
course which was I think in 2014 when I
was a visiting scholar at European
graduate school and got to take that
class all right I'm gonna skip down a
bit because we've got only eight minutes
left
see I'll take people who haven't chimed
in yet and things that I can answer
fairly quickly let's see here
Rayanne I would like to know whether
they're any good comprehensive
introductory books to philosophy of
ethics I mean if you're talking about
like textbooks when I teach I don't use
textbooks anymore I just I have people
read original sources and I provide them
in PDF so I haven't really canvassed
that for a long time I don't know you
know there's anthologies out there that
you know like Khan has this classics of
moral and political philosophy I don't
know about the most recent edition but
you get like you know parts of Plato's
Republic and Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics all the way up to stuff you know
like Mills utilitarianism
I like those anthologies I think those
are good for that
[Music]
well there's a here's an important
question from para toes and I feel like
I'm using philosophy as an excuse to
distance myself from old friends it's
hard to think act on their level
nowadays how do you deal with this well
if you're if it's because philosophy is
changing you that is probably something
you're just gonna have to come to terms
with and you're gonna have to find new
friends or wait for them to start having
experiences that make them open to to
growing in ways and so you know just I
would say just sort of like keep the
channel's open and and I mean nowadays
it's easy to do that you just connect
with them on social media but you don't
you know don't interact until they have
their midlife crisis and then you're
like well you know so incite something
to say about that yeah Brennan writes
I'm sure you've read a Hegel's
philosophy of religion lectures what do
you think about them in its theological
work so as theological workers or early
stuff and I don't I don't find it that
interesting quite frankly his lectures
on the philosophy of religion are quite
interesting I like them especially this
notion that you know when we're when
we're talking about arguments for the
existence of God you know it's less and
Hegel's of you about trying to prove
something and more about the conception
that's involved there and what what
we're trying to learn ultimately about
you know God but that alt means
ultimately about humanity
miss miss Thien why are you interested
in Alistair McIntyre he's a brilliant
thinker started reading his stuff as a
graduate student and I was like holy
crap so much of this stuff makes so much
sense out of the development of
philosophy and why nobody gets anywhere
and having discussions or debates these
days and then I had the opportunity to
study with him in 2005 I think it was he
led a faculty seminar at Notre Dame that
I got to
participate in I had to apply I was the
most junior faculty member involved in
it and got to interact with him you know
quite quite closely and then continued
after that and he's a he's a great
writer a great thinker somebody who
actually follows you know the argument
where it leads and when it comes to
virtue ethics he's one of the people who
not only talks the talk he walks the
walk and you can't say that about
everybody in ethics so that that's
that's great doesn't mean I agree with
everything he says I actually criticized
him on some stuff oh okay so here's a
good follow-up from Tara since you
answered the earlier question what's
your opinion and the counter
enlightenment thinkers like demised
denotes with Cortes and de Bono
I haven't read Cortes but the other guys
those traditionalists so what they're
saying is interesting and part of it is
it has to do with like you know the the
importance of you know ritual and and
you could call it social structure
belief systems and language and they're
they're they're prefiguring what's what
many other people are saying later on
and I also think that that comps thought
in some respects it's kind of a mirror
image of what they're doing I mean I
don't buy their some of their their
conclusions I don't buy some of their
starting points but it is very
interesting work I don't think the
Revolution was like the end of the
European Society or anything like that
and they also by the way fit into you
know the sort of leading up to Shalimar
on and and oxygen Francaise now
interestingly enough traditionalism gets
condemned by the very institution that
it's taking as you know it's it's it's a
most important one which is the Catholic
Church
what does oxygen front says as well so I
think they're worth they're worth
studying and nobody nobody really reads
them much these days just people like me
but they're interesting you know alright
Darth numerous do you have any interest
in Middle Eastern philosophy I do but
not enough to actually you know get me
to be competent in it so I you know I
we're fortunate the mark Marquette
University has the Aquinas in the Arabs
project and we often get some really
cool presentations that I'll go to to
listen to you know to them but I'm there
just as a beginner really alright let's
let's scroll down a bit marksmen do you
only study works in English no I read I
read books in five different languages
and there's a whole video about that let
me see if there's any other short ones I
can I can get to to do what do I think
about Heidegger's black notebooks this
is from Jan Coyle does it invalidate his
artwork doesn't invalidate it but it
sure it sure makes it hard to argue that
well you know the nasty thing was just
kind of a blip clearly it was not but no
it doesn't invalidate his other works
but you know it means that when somebody
says Heidegger was a Nazi there's you
can't wiggle out of that so yeah we're
almost up to the the end let's see here
there's a lot
back and forth here from people who bruh
says a series on mythology would be
amazing well you know maybe down the
line that would be be a lot of work
though oh here's a good one watch him or
Schopenhauer and Insull though
Schopenhauer could get the ladies when
he wanted to so no he wasn't he wasn't
an in cell but he was also you know he's
a pretty misanthropic guy that he
respects and I don't know if you've ever
read his remarks on women but man there
is some stuff in there you know it's
kind of funny because the whole insult
thing is something we could talk about
it much greater like but there's reasons
why some guys who are in cells are in
cells because if given the things that
they think believe and talk about it's
not not likely that somebody hearing
that would want to be involved with them
in a relationship so it's sort of like
you know that that line is very
different context but that line in
revolution the Beatles song you go
around carrying pictures of Chairman Mao
you're not gonna make it with anyone
anyhow all right you know some people I
have to change in my beliefs then then
you know it's repressing my
individuality well I don't know I mean
I've changed my beliefs many times in
part because I had people say well
you're really kind of a jerk talking
about that stuff
and I you know made me think and say
well how could they say that
and then I'd think through it and oh
yeah yeah maybe maybe I don't have to
interpret things this way maybe this is
this is a better and not just better
like pragmatically oh I'm gonna get what
I want but closer to the truth sort of
things sometimes you need people to give
you a kind of a kick in the butt that
way
[Music]
let's see I'll see if I got one more
there's a lot of stuff here about
Catholicism people got into Kevin asks
what's what's my opinion on the books
wolfies world unfortunately I can't say
anything once I haven't read it people
have been recommending it to me and I
will probably have my kids take a look
at it this summer but I haven't I
haven't read it so here's here's what a
good one to end on from odd Quay not a
reference to the dude but am I the only
one who thinks dr. Greg would be an
interesting movie actor that could
possibly be the case I would definitely
need to continue my my working out I'm
still not actually losing any weight but
I am like gaining muscle and losing fat
because you can't be you can't really I
mean unless you're a method actor I'm
not a method actor like what do they
call them you've got these slots that
you fit into it's not like somebody's
gonna like pull me out of the blue and
say you know this guy perfect for this
role or something like that
I'd probably have to you know trim this
up a bit better they probably want me to
color my hair or something like that and
put contacts in or some some nonsense
like that so I I don't I don't
anticipate that happening anytime soon
but I will tell you about something that
I would love to do down the line and
that'll be kind of a cool closing thing
so so one of my longtime supporters and
correspondents and has become a friend
over over the years suggested to me you
know not right now but but down the line
you should like pitch a series a series
about philosophy to Hulu or Netflix or
Amazon or one of these places that has
money to throw at you know real studio
production and pitch them like a real
philosophy show not not a [ __ ]
here's a little bit of Plato and a
little bit of Socrates from shot from
someplace in Greece and will tell you a
little bit about this and a little bit
about this but something that would be
engaging but also have some real meat to
it you know and I think it would be a
really cool idea I'd love to do
something like that but right now I
don't have the the sort of platform or
or the time I got to many different
projects going on to to really pitch
that but that may be something possible
down the line so I'm gonna say thank you
to everybody who showed up I didn't get
to everybody's questions unfortunately
you know I try to handle the ones first
first it's always impossible to get to
all of them but but I'll say say thanks
anyway thanks to all my patreon
supporters who make doing this sort of
thing viable for me and we've got
another philosophy pop up later this
month we're talking about triggering
again and remember if there's any other
online events this month but every every
month we have these AMA sessions so if
you didn't get your question answered
this time maybe you know put it at the
top next time have a great rest of the
weekend those of you who are over in
Europe have a great evening those of you
here in in the this hemisphere
hemisphere I think so
in the Americas have a great afternoon
and those who are on the other side have
a great morning so I'll see all of you
hopefully somewhere else in the ether